the all-star cast of Mamma Mia is back
for more sun sea and ABBA songs
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm talking about the very
best and the not-so-great bits of the
mummy a sequel and comparing it to the
original movie so obviously I'll be
discussing spoilers by the way keep
watching for details of my very special
Mamma Mia giveaway because Mamma Mia 2
is both a prequel and the sequel we get
lots of new actors joining the original
cast and they're all really great a
particular standout is Lily James who
plays the young Donna she really has
tons of energy and spirit in the role a
great voice really gives it all in the
dance routines and works brilliantly
with all the new actors playing the
younger versions of her friends and
lovers then there's also Jeremy Irvin
who plays the young salmon he is just
fantastic in the role now when I first
heard that he'd been cast as the young
Pierce Brosnan character I wondered why
he hadn't been cast as the young version
of Colin first character Harry instead
because he's done that before very well
in a film called the railway man but as
a young Sam in Mamma Mia - Ivan really
does do an incredible take on a young
Pierce Brosnan Hugh Skinner and Josh
Dylan are also great as the young Harry
and bill also new to the caster's Murray
/ Crassus who plays Sofia who gets some
little scene-stealing moments especially
a short scene that she has with the
young Sam which I thought was just
perfect
also just brilliant in this film is the
actress who plays young Tanya and she's
called Jessica keen and win she
absolutely perfectly channels the spirit
of christine baranski Tanya again Mike
Jeremy Irving with Pierce Brosnan she's
not doing an impression of christine
baranski
but she's taking those aspects a little
idiosyncrasies in the way she speaks her
cadence and things taking some of them
putting them into the younger role of
Tanya but also bringing other things
apart as well young Rosie who's played
by Alexa Davies also brings some nice
little moments as well so you can really
look forward to seeing those two on
screen and the moment where young Tanya
tells young Sam that she visually enjoys
him is just priceless as for the
returning cast I cannot get enough of
Christine Baranski and Julie Walters as
Donna's friends and fellow dynamos Tanya
and Rosie beauty comes not only
exquisite structure of your bones and
left in your sparkling eyes but from the
goodness that flowers within you like a
fountain
I've been washed and brought to my tent
I don't think fountains flower did that
remind us and then there's a hilarious
way they sing angel eyes to Sophie with
christine baranski
tanya hardly letting julie walters rosie
get a word in edgeways
of course the prequel aspect of this
film means there are obviously fewer
scenes with the original cast which of
course is a bit of a shame because
they're all so great so for example
while we do see Colin Firth stellan
skarsgård and Pierce Brosnan sing dance
and act we do see them doing less of
that than we did in the first film
speaking of the original cast someone I
would have loved to have seen much more
of is Meryl Streep astana I just adored
scenes Streep singing dancing and acting
with gusto in the first film and I
really did miss her here now while we
certainly don't get enough Meryl Streep
in the movie we do get the added benefit
of cher in a role that was written
specifically for her and which fits her
like a glittery glove is it a touch
insane that sure he's only three years
older than Meryl Streep in real life
it's playing Donna's mother of course it
is
do I care absolutely not because at the
end of the day we get to hear Sher Singh
Fernando complete with a big fireworks
display and we get some crazy moments
with Sophie's grandma now when it comes
to the music obviously in the first film
we got an absolute turn of Abbas biggest
greatest hits which means that in this
film we get some lesser-known Abba
tracks like when I kiss the teacher why
did it have to be me kisses of fire and
undone taen Dante I've been waiting for
you and my love my life but we do also
get some songs that weren't in the
original film that you will I think
definitely recognize there's the name of
the game which is performed by Lily
James there's knowing me knowing you
which is again Lily James and Jeremy
Irvin and there's also angel eyes and
Fernando as well and not to worry
because we do still get many of the
hugely popular hits from the first film
so there's Mamma Mia dancing Queens
super trouper and Waterloo to name a few
for dancing Queen we get a flotilla of
fishermen along with stellan skarsgård
and Colin Firth recreating the Titanic
pose as they sail to
Island and for Waterloo it's in a
Parisian restaurant with a young Harry
and Donna and we even get an Abba cameo
as well with Benny playing the piano and
Mamma Mia gets a spirited performance by
the young dynamos this time when the
film proper ends we get a fantastic
version of Super Trouper with all the
main cast joining in
while Super Trouper was amazing I was a
little bit disappointed that we only got
one song and dance routine in the kind
of curtaincall cast party moment in the
film this time around because last time
if you remember we got two songs we got
dancing Queen and Waterloo so it would
have been fantastic if we just got one
more now if you stay to the very end of
the credits after everyone's names
rolled by we do get a little unexpected
extra something with an unexpected post
credits scene which makes up a little
bit for only one extra song after the
film finishes the post credits scene
features comic actor homage Lili as the
Greek official who was checking people's
passports before they boarded the Island
Ferry earlier in the film if you
remember he had quite a few opinions
about what people look like in their
passport photos compared to real life
and usually told them they look better
in the photo except in the case of Colin
Firth's Harry who he said looked great
and had aged like a fine wine if you
missed the post credits scene it
basically shows a young Harry has
followed Donner to Greece where the
Greek official tells him if she rejects
you give me a call then he follows up
his proposition by singing a few lines
from take a chance on me overall then
while there are some more melancholy and
wistful moments in this film compared to
the first there's still a boatload of
joyous effervescent scenes overflowing
with great song and dance routines and
though it's not quite the non-stop
charmer the original was my my how could
I resist it so yes I did thoroughly
enjoy Mamma Mia too and we'll definitely
be watching it again hopefully soon now
how do you think The Mummy a sequel
compares to the first film and what are
your favourite moments or songs in the
new movie if you want to take a chance
on winning one of these awesome Mamma
Mia 2 merch packs make sure you
subscribe and leave me a comment about
the film and also tap the gleam link in
the video description below to register
your entry I've got new Mamma Mia videos
coming up so tap left to watch the next
one or tap right my full Mamma Mia
playlist if you
like this I really appreciate a thumbs
up thanks for watching and see you next
time you became movie lovers